oh yeah Josh aww star wars the force
awakens final trailer came out yesterday
and we are so freaking excited is the
last trailer we will be seeing until the
movie's release we've got our tickets
it's happening it's so soon and it looks
so good it looks good so we've been
watching this trailer over and over we
want to talk about it there's going to
be some spoilers but I wouldn't be
surprised if like almost none of them
actually happened in the movie so we
want to go through this thing so how's
it start it starts with her name is ray
this is the character on jakku she is
you know like a scavenger clearly just
like repelling spelunking down this
hornstra the Star Destroyer crashed on
jakku right yeah we keep seeing her
we're usually here okay here i love this
one you know what's cool about this I
stopped pointed out is this is an ad at
foot Oh on the right hundred percent
correct I didn't even notice that you're
right sideways so clearly and you can
you seen this inn trailers out
throughout is there's been a war on
jakku there's remains a great place for
scavengers um this is very Luke
Skywalker ask you know again this movie
is so heavily tapping into the original
trilogy it's a salute Scott Walker gave
me off this planet a lot of people are
saying like at first especially that she
is Han and Leia's kid right but I think
that could be like some nostalgia for
the extended universe she could be
Luke's kid she could just be a random
person but I wouldn't be surprised if
she was a Skywalker mmm she in like man
she really does she looks like Luke she
looks like Mark Hamill if you ask me oh
yeah right there you also get these new
I forget what they're called but these
flamethrower stormtroopers Eric in like
the third row from the person's
foreground and we've seen this scene
from multiple angles right the rumors
this is on Starkiller base which you've
seen a bigger version of now on the
poster so this is a base on a planet
that has a weapon built into it rumor is
it can destroy a star which would in
turn destroy a solar system oh so here
we got
Finn uh which looks like I mean I just
know mrs. now looks like a bunch of
blood on his helmet like what is up with
that so we've seen other trailers of him
like he seems like he just saw some [ __ ]
he just he just saw some [ __ ] this is
like bill said this is like my favorite
shot of many just the music kicks in
here we're and now we're actually
hearing people speak and this kylo Ren
this voice is killer so this was a huge
deal when I saw this so that is the
character poe dameron who is a rebel
pilot you keep seeing one in the x-wing
of booking across the water he is he's
definitely getting tortured for
information he must have been captured
at some point in the movie but he could
possibly be being converted to the sis
ya like like you don't see just like
broke his mind a bit like made them a
little easier to manipulate mass
destruction this could be from
Starkiller base maybe a star's going
supernova in the background destroying a
planet mm-hmm okay and then here we go
them the music's kicking in we're
hearing so many even tunes from classic
Star Wars like and then the vo is
they're talking about the stories about
the Jedi and the dark side being true
right so the world's a lot different
than the extended universe one it seems
like after this big war was thought
which everyone knows about like people
forgot about Luke Skywalker's role and
maybe some of Darth Vader's role or
maybe it was a history was changed a bit
by the victor perhaps yeah that's what I
like this trailer reminded me two is
like yeah it's been 30 years as you said
of you know the war going on but even
longer yeah these Jedi just been not
around in the public eye so it's uh
that's insane sure like if you imagine
the people on course on or something
hearing that the death star was
destroyed like how would they know that
Luke Skywalker was on the bridge in like
had Darth Vader turned good and then
threw them for down the hole they don't
know they just know that it blew up and
there were casual
right this is one of coolest this is
almost no cooler like it's just this
ragtag gang so there have been confirmed
actors in this and we don't know their
roles so a couple guys I'm really hoping
are in this gang are the guys from the
raid movies the raid redemption they're
like insane martial artists from
Indonesia I'm pretty sure and like it
would be amazing to see these guys do
some really cool martial arts like
wrecking sew some of the rumors are that
there's a division in the Empire there's
the first order which is something that
was created that basically shuns and
denies all SIF and force tions they're
more militaristic and then you got
Knights of Ren these guys who are so
rumored supposedly like are on the
outskirts of the solar system or the
galaxy trying to find remnants of like
an ancient Sith like religion so here is
this was this act I've seen this so many
times but this was something that blew
my mind so if you go back a little bit
yes they're booking across the water
there attacking something and then you
see this next shot I didn't notice until
later but there they are in the upper
left here those are the x-wings tearing
up water like a flight of Valkyries from
Apocalypse Now it's just like intense
and then you get is probably one of the
coolest battles this reminds me of like
rogue squadron punch stuff like it's on
it's like in the forest area of the
water it's in the atmosphere you can see
two different ships here in one's black
and one's white that's an excellent
there yeah so yeah different x-wings
could be different squadrons difference
quadrants yeah that's we have this
there's a rumor going around that
basically this PO character is in his
own kind of like elite rogue squadron um
hence the black I'd be so excited if
they called it rogue squadron yeah
pretty cool here clearly we have no idea
what's going on yeah where they are what
they're looking for but it has been
pointed out on the internet that this
flag in the top middle is the
Mandalorian logo right Mandalorians are
the creators of the Bubba Fett armor the
Jango Fett armor I mean so this is also
a mash-up of many flags so to say
they're going to see my DeLorean people
is one thing but it's it could just be
like you know I can embassy I don't know
pretty cool detail though it was a nice
easter egg if nothing else so Allah is
some recycled shots from other trailers
that's that's rumored to be Luke okay so
if this is Luke in like if this is a
desert planet which could be jakku like
this could kind of like maybe that's
reading a lot into it but phasma and her
team here could be looking for Luke and
like Ben and Ray and Han could have
gotten like caught in the middle of all
this too mmhmm yeah they are just
terrorizing something right here so is
this luke I don't know it looked like a
pretty thin arm actually that's
definitely a robot arm I guess he
doesn't need skin on it he could have
stripped it down to bare so um phasma is
here captain phasma I think this is the
only shot you see of her in this trailer
it is did not get a lot of screen time
here not much we can infer from here so
what's he doing he's what I don't like
pretty violent used to that lightsaber
he looks he looks vicious he is vicious
good [ __ ] vicious so this is one of
the most contentious shots in the tree
yeah uh there have been make spoilers on
this one or rumors on this one you don't
know but it is rumored to be Chewbacca
it's a different rumor oh so what did
you see because the only reason is in
the bottom right there's like that we
called bandolier kind of like yeah
classic streptococcal repack thing yeah
the rumor I saw is his head is on the
right and his elbow is right here and if
you boost the contrast there's like a
red stripe here and it looks like John
boyega jacket and let's go to the last
shot
hey same jacket him look at it does not
look like he's about to win this fight
no he's definitely not gonna win that
fight so I mean I damn damn I didn't
even realize how you write snowing it
and it's at night cool all right and
then okay let's just you know go crazy
what if he gets his arm cut off right
right and then I norm touch it she's
just got he's just yeah she's just
holding his I'm if he if he got is a
right arm cut off then you know and also
one of the kind of jokes of Star Wars is
like if you use the Skywalker lightsaber
like you get oh yeah your arm cut off
it's it's a burden so it's the blue one
right cuz it happened to fader it
happened to Luke the force oh great so
we got bb-8 it's cool seeing BBA in the
back doing the OL r-two astromech droid
kind of back of thing he's helping we've
seen this kind of stuff a few times it's
always awesome so you're Starkiller base
yes we can kind of see that same trench
this time though different from the
stars it's like built into a planet
rather than completely artificial at
least it looks that way could be like
halo where they have like landscape on
an artificial thing but it suggested to
see if it'll be blown up in this movie
or if it's gonna last longer than one
also this is so Return of the Jedi yeah
just really glad
great okay look at all these villagers
in the background like yeah there's
gonna be like a big showdown this is
going to be like a pivotal moment kind
of like when Anakin killed the
younglings i feel ya oh he's bad this is
more of a luddite awesome cg flying
through Super Star Destroyer oh look
it's that little drug from the desk oh
yeah the bogner there you go Leia
confirmed and then BAM and this was
insane so you got kylo Ren with his
helmet hollering with all his Adam
driver hair yeah I mean cuz we've seen
shots of him and like Vanity Fair and
stuff mm-hmm so he does take his helmet
off it's I think it's just more of a you
know gimmick like he's clearly obsessed
with Vader she wants to be like him like
every day of his life and yeah lots of
people are hamlets without necessarily
needing the life-support system like
storm troopers and then yeah you can see
this is just a silly like he's like
determined guys and then if you go
through this you can just see him like
change his mind right when this the red
one comes in Oh Shh also look at you can
see just like there's this splitting of
the blade it's just such a right savage
blade it's just so yeah like almost
broken like it's just like spitting
flame instead of like the smooth plasma
of the Jedi ones and yeah holy sit well
great Josh um you guys enjoyed that if
you want to talk about it will probably
be chatting with you guys in the
comments so leave your opinions and any
speculation you've got you guys all take
care now bye bye now
you